[Music]
this
is going to be completely unprecedented
it is going to affect medicine in ways
we've never seen before
you can match a blood transfusion to a
blood type
what if matching a cancer cure to our
genetic code
was just as easy just as standard
and that's the promise of precision
medicine delivering
the right treatments at the right time
every time to the right person
precision medicine enables the ultimate
delivery of personalized medicine which
means that you come to your doctor
you have your genetic information and
the doctor can use that genetic
information to specifically design
treatments for you but obviously there
will be
thousands of individuals that have your
disease and your gene
and so it's personal for you but it's
also treating large numbers of people in
the same situation
[Music]
we can look at individual tumors we can
even look at individual
cells within tumors and understand how
their
system is going to arrive it's possible
to analyze this very complex data
using state-of-the-art computer
algorithms
to be able to see the interaction
of proteins in a cancer cell and to
design drugs that
will inhibit or treat them a really good
example
of how all this works is with a drug
called gleevec
and this is a drug for a certain type of
leukemia
this drug had a miraculous effect i mean
it basically cured the disease
however the individuals will receive
this six months a year later it was back
then a second drug was developed we had
the tools to go back
look at the sequence of that reverted
protein and know where the change was
and then design
a second drug to address that and now
the combination of those two drugs that
are used in sequence
basically has cured one form of this
disease
and so i think that's what's going to
happen there'll be more and more
examples
of cases where we can join genetics
biology and medicine
in heart disease the chairman of
physiology andy marks
has been studying a receptor that is
absolutely central to
how the heart functions and recently
they determined the three-dimensional
structure of this protein
that has then led very quickly to the
development of small molecule drugs that
address certain heart diseases
that defines precision medicine because
it can't be more precise than having
a high resolution three-dimensional
structure that tells you something about
the human disease
what's so exciting is that we have the
possibility of leading
an entirely new era of medicine that
makes sure new jobs and new industries
and new life-saving treatments for
diseases are created right here in the
united states
five years ago it was about ten thousand
dollars to sequence a whole genome
ten years before that almost a billion
dollars was spent
worldwide in sequencing this today we
can sequence a whole genome
in 24 hours for 1500
but when you take 1500 times the number
of people
you need to see before you begin to
learn the relationship between the
genetics and medicine
that's a very big number it is difficult
to forecast exactly
what the financial implications of
precision medicine are going to be
on the one hand if drugs are tailored to
very specific populations
the prices are higher because the value
to the patient is also higher
on the other hand today many people are
taking drugs that are really not doing
them any good
we can avoid the unnecessary costs of
inappropriate
medication that would be cost saving
it's important for the lay public to
understand that this doesn't happen
overnight
the genetics is now straightforward we
can sequence
very rapidly very cheaply but we still
have to add on to that
the drugs developing and that takes time